I can't stop listen to chance the rapper
it's a great album that's so great about
you know what I love that well I listen
to it I don't have any expectations and
I was like wow this was a lot like the
first time I listened to Kanye's for
Salman yeah and then I'd know you some
Chicago yeah thing and then and then the
other you know what else it gives me a
little bit of a vibe of thank you
there's like a little there's some parts
that makes me feel like like when he
talks yeah there's a talking there's a
talking version of graph that I really
like that I've noticed is it yeah we got
it
biggie did it like I like the guys who
talk like people are saying oh they
finally bit him in the ass I mean it's
like no their whole reason they're here
is because I have you know what I mean
like you know it's a big part of what
makes them then like you know this is
like this is the trade-off three months
just the dream on just a basketball
version of me it's actually it's it's
really how I play basketball I'm like
okay I don't you know I'll kick anybody
yeah and have no problem with him like
I'm sorry it's just that out of it this
is how I play right I'm just not
talented or Humongousaur amazing but
like I'm a dirty player yeah I
understand that it's just its
competitiveness slightly off kilter to
the wrong direction
yeah but without it all the other good
doesn't happen it's a real basketball
this morning
I'm on a continuous quest try to spend
more time with people to do renovation
and so Jeff and I were having runny nose
okay listen do me a favor put together a
small group shoot the [ __ ] and say hey
and talk about stuff and maybe give you
guys a little access in this kind of
environment to like for me the answer to
come on your mind
actually like yours the best I just
think there's like a good diversity you
play candy crush
I love it you know what's interesting
about us as a collective this is the
first time I've seen this this is
probably the least amount of fold or use
I've ever seen it so I thought
interesting that I'm the only one that's
using folders from all my social snap so
look at you several versions the first
thing you know actually this was about
yeah yeah so you're really like and if
you notice it's within your thumbs reach
so you're actually living just here so I
think the uninteresting thing is like
this is like a lot of what people yeah
that's true it doesn't matter because
mine's like I'll get like these the ones
I use this oh so you also left oh
there's a ball people don't blame yeah
this is your first screen yeah okay wait
a minute
oh we've some oh you don't clean it for
screen I use like my second and third
yeah I find that so anything like it's
like oh I can't touch this I'm gonna
move to the second page John literally I
think he goes to prison this any other
day this to me is like the typical like
I'm under 205 music and snapchat uber I
live in New York Maps this is like this
is yeah super basic no folders yes
I don't update my absence
seriously
I know it's my job I actually think
instagrams in a weird horrible position
though I don't like how they're getting
squeezed right now between snapchat and
Facebook but Facebook has its generation
and just snapchats eating up too much of
what is read had the Apple Google or is
the most interesting one in tech from
the standpoint of actually think Apple
can you very much white the most major
search engine that's a billion dollars
and a big real hardcore ad blocking like
absolutely care about banner actually
like I had met you that's nothing but
for Gilbert right that's right
subwoofers like like for them to kill
all banner in this environment really
hurts Google so that dance is
interesting to me what I think is more
interesting is how nobody hears and the
business world understands that there is
no other debate the only debate isn't
mobile and the only sub debate is maybe
ass consumption or browser consumption
in a world where everybody here are
still doing business and a desktop
mentality that's what's interesting
the number one thing that I wish would
happen in the tech business world is
Facebook producing an actual television
this is my dream that Facebook gets into
the hardware business makes a television
so that we can then take the content
from our feeds and throw them right on
the TV your app is connected to your
your feed is connected to your TV and
and I just really think Facebook would
win I think controlling the hardware is
more important than people realize and I
think it's a very logical important move
for Facebook so
you happy with it is it invasive are you
okay with it I'm super cool with it it's
super cool like it's gonna be like Mike
could you imagine watching a great
grandfather right now it'd be crazy like
that's what people don't understand like
I'll take the short-term heat of like
people like your narcissistic you're a
buck immediate you're this whatever and
I'm like cool first of all it's the same
[ __ ] all it's like all of you were gonna
do it
nobody's created tag video where you
like create with one tape and then like
let them tag to all their presidents and
so they can like basically pull in a
final piece that's combination of your
content yep your content my content it's
all is a world in which like Justin
Bieber creates a take of his first video
it's a matter with this guy I feel like
he just scheduled a normal meeting I
feel like I just might 10:30 got
scheduled what was that like I hope that
was something good what was that just a
normal like 11:30 July seventh meeting
booked yep I just want to have a
conversation where it's not about your
idea for how you're gonna raise your
next round like it's just it's like hard
it's like hard to have a conversation
with somebody that wants to talk about
their business they're all doing that
because it's commoditized they're not
building anything their planes LTP and
CAC to the [ __ ] cows come home and
they're not building any real brand and
then the market changes on them because
Pinterest gets expensive and I had a
business I don't know just feels like
feels like there's just a lot of like
there's a there's a lot of opportunity
for the people that really know what
they're doing but way too much of wheat
we all of us have created in last decade
a financial arbitrage northstar not a
build a business nor stock finest series
a at all costs series bienick like what
is now they were person community you
like that's what they're doing they're
trying to figure out what metric or what
thing is gonna make you click to lead
the next thing and then all the behavior
goes there even if it's at the peril of
the actual business
and the reason we've been able to do
that is more money than pumpkin and when
there's not
it gets really nasty and like real
companies are they're glad business like
big ones this early I guess they four
seconds ago after you do this every day
I mean right now all right now I know I
traitor show that's right that's hell
CMO that's a chief health officer oh I'm
in a crazy place like help lies yeah you
look great
yeah like I've been totally different
place oh I'm up meds like you okay
read the [ __ ] you're busy I'm busy as
[ __ ] but oh this is like you love your
passion all that [ __ ] everybody thinks
I'm crazy right now
like only cuz only cuz no no busy
because there wasn't snapchat and
dailyvee or and nobody really realized
how hard I was really
that's what very good point speed no I'm
in the I'm in the happiest second of my
life right now
I mean that's yours good to see you
thank you that's a salad face
if I'm gonna eat at [ __ ] 10:30 this
early like after breakfast give me a
heads up so I can tell you something
like like I would eat sushi now in four
seconds but I can't eat this sushi now
yes go downstairs and get me sushi very
Japanese thank you some protein is
easier to consume than others here you
go you know like I just got to
communicate to you like what it is like
sushi I told you that the other day yeah
salad sometimes become so daunting to me
like but sushi has struggled to ever
become too much and I feel like there's
more protein I mean there's you could
map it out exactly it's a lot easier for
me to consume all this protein like this
took I'm already done cool
huge announcement I'm coming Shirley
check my Twitter
what's our gonna see if I postpone some
things just went because Gary called me
and said we have an announcement
announcement and I said this better be
good and it turned out it is you are
announcing yeah that you are starting a
sports agency that's right I really give
a crap we're really gonna do this you
know what I'm most excited about
we are gonna force in a decade every
sports agent to care more about their
guys we're gonna that's what I want my
Wikipedia entry to say that Vayner
Sports made the entire industry do more
right by the athlete because the
competitive bar got raised that's what
we did is when the new wine business for
customers and that's what I did in
vaynermedia for the agency world and
that's what we're gonna do at their
sports banner sports y'all banner sports
what up equinox
I mean a mic give me the mic
I think the reason I am what I am and
have what I have and like I'm as happy
as I as I am is because I got blessed
with big-time mental health we've always
thought about people winning the lottery
like genetically like oh you're a
good-looking guy right and you're like
good at school like you Europe and some
hardware going you want but like that's
right like the [ __ ] that I actually won
on like the thing that and like [ __ ]
like [ __ ] like everybody thinks I'm a
de contrôle like every comment of
socials like this guy [ __ ] does
enormous amounts of drugs and I've done
zero and like with all my insanity like
I'm [ __ ] some level because I'm
pulling hard from two very opposite
directions
I got nothing